hello everyone uh
uh
welcome we are going to uh each give
some prepared remarks and then answer
your questions
i will begin followed by minister
mendocino and then minister blair
are we ready
good morning
good afternoon
i would like to begin by acknowledging
that i am speaking to you today from the
traditional territory of the algonquin
anishinaabe peoples
i want to provide you with a brief
update uh i want to provide canadians
with a brief update on where we are in
the process of implementing the public
order emergency declared under the
emergencies act
that is
the emergencies act spells out a clear
process that must be followed once an
emergency is declared
yesterday the orders and regulations
that allow us to take action were
published in the canada gazette
they outline in specific terms
our clear
targeted and proportionate response to
this crisis
as the emergencies act stipulates the
orders and regulations made yesterday
must be tabled in the house of commons
within two days of their release
that will happen before the end of the
day tomorrow
looking ahead both the house of commons
and senate will soon have the
opportunity to debate and vote on the
emergency declaration
we are required to table the written
declaration in both houses within seven
sitting days
as well
parliament can amend or revoke any
orders we have made
this is an important democratic check
and balance in the act
we will be moving quickly
to commence debate
canadians expect and deserve nothing
less
declaration
obtained
the emergencies act is much more limited
in scope
it is allowing us to use targeted and
proportional measures to help bring the
illegal blockades and occupations to an
end
and critically
all of our actions under the emergencies
act will comply with the charter of
rights and freedoms
that requirement is built into the
legislation itself
it is an important and necessary
safeguard
toothless
canadians expect their government to act
within the bounds of the charter and we
will live up to that expectation
thank you nfc i turned the microphone
over to minister mendocino
i'd also like to acknowledge that i'm
joining from the traditional territories
of the algonquin people
thank you for joining us for today's
update on the federal government's
ongoing response to the illegal blockade
these illegal blockades pose a national
security threat to our borders our
economy and to the health and safety of
all canadians
to begin i am pleased to report that
three of the most important border
crossings in canada are now open to
trade and travel
in alberta the coots border crossing
reopened yesterday after the successful
enforcement operation by the rcmp
in british columbia the pacific highway
border crossing south of surrey has also
reopened after enforcement action
including 12 arrests
and in windsor the ambassador bridge
where roughly a quarter of canada's
daily commercial trade
was blocked for almost a week is now
reopened
and in manitoba
i can inform that the rcmp
and cbsa
are hoping to reopen the emerson border
crossing
later today
this means that alberta beef
bc salmon and manitoba pork
can once again be exported to markets
across north america
the successful work that is being done
in windsor by the police service there
in conjunction with the rcmp and opp to
end the illegal blockade
has resulted in some 50 arrests
and 90 charges
this means that families in windsor
oakville ingersoll alliston and so many
other communities know that they will be
able to go back to work
in the morning and earn a paycheck
trade is now flowing in both directions
and i'm pleased that factories across
southern and ontario have resumed
production
and as we know the rcmp made 13 arrests
earlier this week at the coots border
crossing and seized a significant number
of lethal firearms a large supply of
ammunition
body armor high-capacity magazines and a
machete
and yesterday
four men were charged by the rcmp
with a conspiracy to murder officers
as the deputy commissioner of the rcmp
noted and i quote
monday's weapons seizure and subsequent
arrests speak to the serious criminal
activities taking place during the
protest and illegal blockades
the dangerous criminal activity
occurring away from the tv cameras and
social media posts was real and
organized
it could have been deadly for citizens
protesters and officers
we need to be clear-eyed about the
seriousness of these incidents
indeed several of the individuals at
kutz have strong ties
to a far-right extreme organization with
leaders who are in ottawa
we're talking about a group
that is organized
agile
knowledgeable and driven by an extremist
ideology
where might makes right
and this is completely contrary
to our democratic values
on monday the government took the
deliberate step of invoking the
emergencies act for the first time in
our country's history
the declaration gives targeted temporary
and special authorities to law
enforcement to help them
the powers exercised are intended to
give law authorities new tools to not
only bring down the blockades but to
prevent future similar ones and threats
by maintaining security at our borders
legislatures and other critical
infrastructures
be last night we shared the orders which
detail exactly how the act will be
implemented
in particular it outlined how an
individual must not participate in a
public assembly that may be reasonably
expected to lead to a breach of the
peace
i'm pleased to say that earlier today
that local authorities here in ottawa
began to issue warnings under that
provision
there are also provisions under the
declaration that allows us to dispute
the movement of people or trade
interfering with critical infrastructure
or supporting or threatening violence
against people or property
over the past three weeks
we have seen all of this and more on the
streets of ottawa and at major border
crossings
and it must stop
this is a serious situation
we must resist the temptation to dismiss
these as isolated incidents
at the core of the movement is anger
animosity and in far too many cases
violence
we're seeing it play at our borders in
front of our legislatures our national
symbols and in our communities and in
our neighborhoods
unfortunately many residents in ottawa
have had the same
experience
the situation
exactly
important
the
situation to those who may be thinking
to come to ottawa this weekend
don't
at best
the residents of the city have made it
clear
that this is not the time
and at worst
you may be tying yourself to dangerous
criminal activity
this has been an extraordinarily
difficult two years for all canadians
and everyone's mental health has
suffered
but for those who've had their community
occupied or can't go to work or can't
live their lives
the past three weeks have been simply
unacceptable
and it's unsustainable we owe it to them
and to all canadians to end the illegal
blockades and to help get canadians
lives back thank you merci and i will
now turn it over to my colleague and
friend minister bill blair
well thank you very much minister
mendocino and minister lametty and good
afternoon everyone and
thank you for being here with us today
as you have heard on monday our
government invoked the emergency act in
order to supplement and support
provincial and territorial authorities
to address the ongoing black aids at a
number of key border crossings across
the country as well as to help deal with
the serious situation that we are seeing
here
in ottawa
let me acknowledge to you all that this
is not a decision
that we came to lightly
we recognize this is a very significant
step that requires both caution and a
tremendous amount of care
and let me assure everyone watching here
today
that the measures that we have brought
forward
are targeted
temporary and proportionate to the
threat that exists in our country
i listen very carefully to the leader of
the ndp this morning who asked that
these measures be implemented with care
and with consideration
and we agree
it is important as well
for canadians to recognize that the
emergency act requires that every action
be charter compliant
and that at all times
their rights and freedoms will be
respected
additionally everything that is being
done through this act is subject to
parliamentary oversight and to review
these measures were only invoked after
exhausting all other options and it is
our very sincere hope that we will be
able to lift them
as quickly as possible
we did this in order to keep canadians
safe
to protect our economy
to restore confidence in and and
sustain our institutions
and to ensure the safety of our citizens
i'd like to take the opportunity to
recognize the work of the windsor police
at the and the ontario provincial police
and other police services across ontario
as well as of course the rcmp
in reopening and securing the ambassador
bridge in windsor
the same can be said for the
extraordinary and important work of the
rcmp at the coots border crossing in
alberta the pacific highway border
crossing in british columbia and in
emerson manitoba
but we have also seen
strong evidence that it was the
intention of those who blockaded
our boards of entry in a largely
foreign-funded
targeted and coordinated attack
which was clearly and criminally
intended
to harm canada
to harm canadians
to interrupt vital supply lines to idle
our workers and close our factories
and
it demanded that we all do what was
required
in order
to restore this integrity and security
of our borders and to protect canadian
interests
well we thank
quite sincerely those law enforcers and
our provincial and territorial partners
who have worked hard to this
let me also state unequivocally we
respect
provincial authority over policing in
their jurisdictions
but i believe all canadians also
recognize that the government of canada
has a responsibility to integr protect
the safety and security of our
international borders
to ensure the canadian interests are
addressed and we will do what is
required
to protect our country
i'd also note
that since the imposition
excuse me the announcement of the
measures we intended to take and have
now taken through the gazetting of these
measures
we've seen significant progress
we saw for example excellent and
important
enforcement conducted by the rcmp in
coates alberta with that where as
minister mendocino's indicated a large
number of weapons have been seized and
people have now been charged with
serious criminal offenses directed
towards our law enforcement officers
but we've also seen
that the acknowledgement and recognition
by many of the people at those protests
in in kutz in emerson
in in
british columbia
when they realized that that their
activities would come under greater
financial scrutiny and consequence
they have done what rational people
would do and they are beginning to leave
and open those borders we are achieving
what we intended to achieve with these
measures and we're doing it in the most
proportionate and measured way possible
with commercial vehicles now traveling
unimpeded through these ports of entry
grocery store shelves are being stocked
factories and businesses are receiving
parts and supplies they need and most
importantly hard-working canadians are
able to get back to work
in ottawa i want to acknowledge that we
are seeing progress in the effort to end
the unlawful occupation that has been
had a devastating impact on residents
for nearly three weeks
yesterday acting chief stephen bell
confirmed that the ottawa police service
has the resources
in partnership with the ontario
provincial police and the rcmp and other
police services from across ontario
and as well they now have the
authorities of both the government of
canada and the government ontario to end
the illegal demonstration
that has disrupted the city of ottawa
for far too long we will provide support
to our law enforcement officials to
restore of the rule of law
and a safer environment for the people
of ottawa
as of this morning the ottawa police
service has been serving notice to
individuals who are blocking wellington
street to remind them that illegal
behavior that they are engaging in will
have consequences and our laws will be
enforced
we will continue to support our law
enforcement partners our municipal and
provincial partners as they work
together through the integrated command
center to restore order to our community
and to uphold our laws
these illegal blockades have shown us
that our supply chains are fragile
and when attacked
in a coordinated and concerted effort
we must respond and we must respond with
with resolve
and with strength
we cannot leave anyone with the
impression that our democracy
is negotiable or subject to efforts of
appeasement
canada is a strong and democratic nation
we will not let any foreign entities
that seek to do harm to canada or to
canadians erode trust in our democratic
institutions or the question the
legitimacy
of our democracy
and as minister lametty stated on monday
canada is a rule of law country and by
declaring a public order emergency under
the emergency act we are following the
law
and we are acting within it
thank you very much for
listening to our remarks i would now
open it up to any questions you may have
so we'll start with questions in the
room come on victoria
foreign
[Music]
difficult
[Music]
capacity
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
the circumstances
we'll take three questions on zoom
david aikens
you can go ahead
well thank you very much jim um just i
guess the first question is
you keep speaking about these illegal
blockades plural there's only one it's
outside
all the others were resolved without the
emergencies act by really good law
enforcement the one in surrey the one in
emerson the one in windsor it was good
law enforcement under existing laws
can you explain what is the specific
tool
that the folks in ottawa needed that
will finally get them to enforce a
friggin law pardon my language
i think we can forgive you for a little
bit of color in your in your language
david i think um
we're all feeling it
um and and the short answer is that um
while we've made progress
it's not guaranteed
you're quite right that yes we've seen
the illegal blockades come down in couts
in surrey
um in windsor
and and hopefully later today in emerson
and and while that's not
for certain we
there are many positive indications that
that emerson will be fully opened as
well
and all of the the positive impacts that
that flows on the economy on you know
people's jobs their their job security
their ability to earn a paycheck as i
said in my remarks
to go out
to put food on the table to look after
their children to look after their
parents
or seniors to be able to
go about their lives getting access to
public transportation access to health
care
um
all of the indications right now are
encouraging but they're not
guaranteed and certainly here if you
live
in ottawa
um
you are waiting with um baited breath
now
for uh quite some time in fact
many people are long past the point of
patience and one of the
real concerns that i have
is that if we don't see a resolution to
this more and more people who live in
ottawa may feel obliged to take matters
into their own hands and that would be a
dangerous thing to do
we've seen it in some of the counter
protests where frustration is
beginning to boil over where
people who live here feel completely
helpless and abandoned
and we have to turn that around
we have to turn that around and that's
one of the reasons why we introduced the
emergencies act
it was a unique unprecedented thing to
do
but we took the decision carefully we
took the decision deliberately
to ensure that
law enforcement and existing authorities
could work in concert with these new
powers to put an end to the blockades
and so in spite of the progress that
we've made we have to hold that progress
we have to keep our borders open we have
to keep our economy going we have to
keep canadians at work we have to allow
the people of ottawa to get their lives
back
and we're going to work around the clock
to do that but understand that that work
has to be undertaken by police
the people that put on the uniform the
badge the people that we trust
to keep us safe
and i can think of no better person than
to add a little bit more context to that
than somebody who's worn uh the badge in
the uniform for many many years bill
yeah
thanks very much and and david as we did
in our remarks let me acknowledge the
excellent work that was done by the rcmp
for example in kutz alberta
but let us also acknowledge that that
blockaded kutz alberta went on for two
weeks
and on and and throughout that two weeks
it was hugely impactful on the people of
alberta and on canadians interests
the blockade at emerson has gone on for
several days the blockade at windsor
lasted several days and it forced some
of our auto plants to be idled
and and it was very clear that it was
enormously challenging for law
enforcement using their existing
authorities to have the positive effect
of reopening our borders now the rcmp
in includes alberta took extraordinary
and important enforcement action
yesterday for which we are all grateful
and and they revealed to us something
about the nature of these
uh types of blockades what their what
their scope is and what their intent is
you know and i've i've spent many years
investigating organized crime and i'll
tell you one of the ways in which we
really determined the nature of the
threat and its motivation was to follow
the money
and unfortunately for these protests and
these blockades these illegal blockades
law enforcement did not have the tools
they required to follow the money
and it's also important that
the money be in jeopardy
that that people know that there are
going to be financial consequences for
their illegal activities
and i would note that even in after the
law enforcement action at kutz people
were arrested and taken away but the
trucks were still there
until we announced our intention to
bring forward
measures where we were going to bring
greater scrutiny to the financing of
these these illegal operations and real
consequences for the people that were
engaged in them
that they packed up and went home
similarly there was no enforcement of
the law at emerson
but was
that that caused those people to leave
it was this certainty
that there that there were going to be
real consequences financial consequences
and legal consequences arising from the
measures we introduced
and finally after we saw the damage
that was done to the canadian economy to
canadian interests to our international
reputation to to the industries that
rely so much on the movement of
essential goods and supplies and auto
parts coming back and forth across that
border each and every day
it was very clear that the people that
organized those blockades knew exactly
who they were harming and what they were
doing
and there is no guarantee
that they couldn't set up again within
hours we've already seen them that make
efforts at other border crossings but
with the impossession imposition of
these new measures we have not only
taken action to open those those those
ports of entry that were blockaded but
to protect all ports of entry to protect
all canadian interests from the criminal
intent of the of the people behind these
blockades thanks
thanks very much jensen you'll be
pleased to know that about 15 minutes
ago rcmp manitoba just tweeted that uh
route 75 is open all traffic is moving
you ought to double as a traffic
reporter david so
here you go um just a quick one and i
guess this minister medicine might be mr
very much sure an operational question
since invoking the emergencies act and
specifically on the financial controls
can you tell us how many bank accounts
have been frozen how much money has been
frozen can you give us an update on what
is actually happening to people's uh
corporate or bank accounts or insurance
well
what i think we can say with confidence
is that those authorities are now in
force and that they are being used
uh and it is
incredibly important
that um
that we follow the money
that authorities have the capacity
to follow the money
because for a number of weeks there have
been many alarm bells that have been
going off about the rate at which the
leaders of the blockades have been able
to raise significant funds much of which
has been raised from abroad
and so with those flags
it is important that through the
emergencies act that
um police have these tools that banks
have these tools and not just through
conventional currency but i think more
um more relevantly
um we're seeing alternative platforms
like cryptocurrencies uh being used as a
vehicle uh to fund the efforts that are
going on
uh to uh
to harm canadians and to hurt canadians
and so
uh when it comes to the precise details
of
how many um individuals accounts have
been impacted by this law or
where from and who um at the same time
david you'll appreciate that we have to
respect the boundaries of investigation
and operational independence
and i keep making this point and i'm
going to keep making it so that you your
readers and all canadians understand
the role of government
is to write the laws and to provide the
tools and the resources that police need
but it is up to police to then use those
tools
to end the blockades and to restore
public order and that's the way our uh
that's the way our democracy functions
and for good reason
um you don't want the folks who are
elected to become
um sort of political extensions of
enforcement that can lead to very uh
troubling and dangerous results and i
know that's not what you're suggesting
but it's very important that folks
understand
um exactly where those boundaries and
where those bright lines exist and it's
part of our job to make sure that we
respect them
and i'd like to remind everybody
we have a
definite timeout at
205
so next question will be mary kay walsh
mary kay you can go ahead with your
question
uh it's actually alex ballinger from the
star here i do you guys are trying to
mute me i don't know if i can am i
jumping the queue here or we hear you
okay i'll just i'll just give her um
minister medicine you mentioned uh that
there's there's these ties with the
far-right group between what happened in
kooth and what's going on in ottawa can
you explain exactly what group you're
talking about how big is it how much of
a threat is this to people's safety we
saw a bunch of guns
and body armor and coots are you
concerned there's similar
items in ottawa just please expand on
what you said because that was quite
striking
well i think we're beginning to see what
we're beginning to see emerge now are
the the hallmarks of a um sophisticated
and capable organization of of a small
number of individuals but with a steel
resolve
driven by an extreme ideology
that would uh seek to
create to overthrow the existing
government and create some kind of
parallel structure uh where whereby they
get to dictate the rules based on
untrammeled freedoms and it may sound
far
out there in left field
but
looking back over the course of the
number last number of weeks and more
importantly i'm seeing the developments
of
the arrests and seizures that have been
made this past week um
there's there's
a real danger in trivializing and
diminishing exactly
what's going on here um
and
we we have a good reason to be concerned
about that as canadians do um when we go
to our borders and we can't
um you know get by because
people have armed themselves with the
kind of illegal firearms uh and other uh
weapons to uh to to to use with force
against our authorities
that is uh
extremely uh concerning
and you know likewise what we've seen in
ottawa
is uh in some ways even more complicated
because the people that are
participating and that are driving uh
the the occupation here have become
entrenched
uh so much so that uh you know at times
on wellington it has uh
appeared to be completely lawless
and so that is another reason why
we've introduced the emergencies act
which is to create the additional tools
that are necessary as you've heard
colleagues explain
to give to the police
and to other institutions to restore our
public order
and as time goes on i think it's
becoming clearer and clearer
what exactly is is motivating this group
it is not about vaccines it is not about
vaccine mandates it's not about having a
robust debate about how to get out of
the pandemic
um
canadians have those discussions and
those disagreements all the time we talk
about it at my uh
dining room table and kitchen table just
like everybody else does but that's
completely different than the kind of
behavior and the kind of frankly
disturbing criminal conduct that we're
seeing uh in kutz in emerson
in
surrey uh and in windsor and yes here in
ottawa and and so we just have to be
very clear-eyed about exactly um what
this this group is is trying to advance
and more importantly uh why they're
trying to advance it
just as a follow-up to that i i mean you
talked about
the individuals of coots have strong
ties to a far-right extreme organization
with leaders who are in ottawa are you
talking about the leaders of the convoy
who
sometimes hold press conferences who
we've seen on on social media talking
about fundraising who exactly are you
talking about does the group have a name
what is this far-right organization with
ties between coots and the leaders in
ottawa alex those are very good alex
those are very good questions for law
enforcement and for police all i can
tell you is that what we're seeing is a
a very similar pattern of conduct and
the hallmarks
of of of the
of the ideology and the motivations of
people who are operating in in different
parts of the country who are
trying to interrupt our borders uh
who are tr who are
interrupting daily life here in our
communities they use similar rhetoric
they use similar rallying calls um one
only has to turn to social media
but in in terms of the details uh which
i think you are quite right to ask those
are questions which are best uh put to
uh our law enforcement
mary kay you can now ask your question
asking can you please clarify
yes or no have you seen clear or been
given or told clear evidence of a direct
tie between the people who had the guns
and the motives and plans to kill
officers in alberta
and people who are in the demonstrations
and blockades in ottawa
the
the charges that have been laid
uh in uh couts uh will lay out exactly
um what what it is that uh the police
believe and hope to to prove in a court
of law
um the point that is being made is that
the rhetoric that supported the movement
in kutz is very similar and strikingly
similar to the kind of rhetoric that
we're seeing not only in ottawa but
right across the country and it sheds
light on the
the ideology that is that is motivating
um the small number of organized
individuals who are trying to spread
that message and certainly um are doing
it in a very effective way across social
media
as a means of as a means of of of
undermining public confidence in our
institutions including in law
enforcement and in government and that
is something that should all concern us
when it comes to what it exactly it is
that we are confronting here and one
only has to take a look at the impact
that it has had in our communities um
and i've you know talked about it but
you know this is this is about really
being quite clear-eyed about what's
driving the movement
okay so my takeaway from that is that
you're you are making a link in the
rhetoric but you have not actually seen
anything
that actually
confirms a connection
if that's incorrect please let me know
but i have a follow-up question for my
colleague bill curry
if the government is so certain
in its
uh use of the emergencies act
why are you not committing to having a
vote in a minority parliament this week
to ensure you have the support of the
house of commons for that
i'm going to pass that important
question uh to minister le meteon
processor
uh thank you thank you for that
supplemental question we are going to
follow every single uh rule that that uh
we need to follow with respect to the
use of the emergencies act because they
contain important safeguards so we are
going to debate it in the house and we
are going to have a vote in the house
i'll leave that up to the house leaders
as i said it's going to the debate will
we we think the debate will begin
imminently uh i'll leave it up to the
house leaders to determine how long that
debate goes it has to it has to uh
uh has to be started within seven days
we'll be well within that uh and and we
intend uh to debate this openly
transparently uh and according to the
the checks and balances that are set out
in the act that's one of the reasons why
we chose this act
we have time for one last question in
the room kevin
kevin gallagher with ctv national news
uh minister meniscino i i want to follow
up on marika walsh's question i think
that
um we need to be certain that it sounds
like you are making the connection
between the rhetoric of uh suspects who
you know are accused of attempted and
conspiring to attempt murder in includes
alberta and the organizers here
so is that what your
conclusion is or is that something
that's backed up by evidence of an
ongoing law enforcement investigation no
i think you have it right i mean i think
the pattern that we're seeing here is in
the rhetoric that is being used not only
in couts not only in ottawa but right
across the country
and um you know one uh i think can
observe that very plainly uh in the
in the the similar messages that are
being shared by those who are
participating actively in the blockades
and so
that unif that that unified and focused
message is one of concern and i think
does shed light on the ideological
motivations of those who are prepared to
move beyond just um you know
demonstrations in and crossing into a
different conduct which would be illegal
so then it's
your conclusion
it's it's certainly i think the
conclusion of many individuals and
canadians who are taking a look at
social media and it's uh extremely
concerning
and i'm told you saw that sorry just i
know i know that that was a fall anyways
i just for for the financing how long
can this last i mean if you suspend
someone's account uh banks are concerned
that they're going to be put up to other
legal challenges legal barriers if
they're suspending accounts what kind of
legal accountability does that mean for
major financial institutions how long
can that last can it be suspended
indefinitely i think there's a lot of
questions that canadians have i'll turn
that over to minister la medium process
thank you for the question look the law
the law uh is in force for 30 days it's
temporary uh we have
you've seen that uh
that order that has been promulgated
with respect to the financial rules uh
the financial institutions will work
with law enforcement authorities
to provide the information
that
that then law enforcement authorities
will use
and we will abide by the parameters of
the law
within that and so if it if the law only
is enacted for 30 days unless it's
extended and as we have said we hope
that we'll revoke it well before that
thank you very much this concludes the
press conference
thank you the conference has now ended
you